you ever just feel like seeing a dumb
movie you know like a really dumb movie
like you don't want to go to the theater
and experience some great film you just
kind of feel like taking a load off and
watching something stupid so I was kind
of wondering would you want to see The
Roommate sounds like it could be fun you
know just see some stupid movie hello
so I saw the roommate like two weeks
late cuz every once in a while I just
feel like singing dumb movie that's why
I almost didn't review this because I
was perfectly fine with the idea of
seeing a dumb movie however I know what
I saw so let's talk about at the a I
want so much rather see a dumb scary
movie than a stupid drama or a comedy or
action movie because then I would just
be frustrated by the stupidity a dumb
scary movie I can kind of relish in
because they're just so corny and cheesy
and it's just something fun about
watching a dumb scary movie so anyway
the roommates about a girl who gets a
roommate at college and she's a great
psychopathic person it stars Minka Kelly
and Lee Lee Meister is that her name I
don't even remember I'm sure someone
will comment saying there's something
wrong she starts to get to know the
person seems like all they're nice and
buddies and they're friends and they get
along and everything but then she just
starts asking her all the time where
have you been calling her everywhere she
goes where are you or are you text
messages she starts imitating her she
starts dressing like her she starts
doing everything like her following her
everywhere and she becomes a huge
stalker and she's basically insane I
felt like watching a dumb movie that's
exactly what I got it was really stupid
and poorly acted at many times some
terrible writing basically that's what I
wanted I just wanted to sit back and
watch a stupid movie and this movie's
perfect if you want to watch a dumb dumb
dumb movie Minka Kelly is adorable and
she has these little cute little things
she does what they're acting it's very
obvious she's like
I love thinking behind the camera and
the roommate wow she's bad in this movie
she's really bad Billy Zane is in this
movie listen to your friend Billy Zane
he's a cool dude
yes Billy Zane was in Zoolander that
makes me very happy my friends and I
always laugh at his cameo in Zoolander
cuz it's so hilarious
Billy sings and all the sudden zoo
weather is just great
he was the Phantom just to let you know
so what we get is a whole bunch of
cliche crap basically and it all just
you know it all happens you know it's
gonna happen no it's gonna happen
there's a few scenes that were had some
genuine suspense the majority the scares
in this movie come from bang sound
effects right and that's that's the easy
scares they're cheap scares and the fact
that it scared me is not because of the
film's effectiveness it's because when
you're sitting there in a theater with
you know huge surround sound speakers
and you're just sitting there nonce I'm
just going it's like oh geez I mean it's
unnerving I didn't think it was as bad
as critics said it was I mean it wasn't
bad it was just what are you really
expecting it just filled with horror
cliches it's a cheesy movie it's just 2
out of 4 stars with it for me it's a
dumb movie but that's what I wanted so
whatever dude he totally should have
called me to see The Roommate Billy Zane
was in it
yay I reviewed this and she's a greedy
psychopathic person I shouldn't make
myself laugh this much I love the camera